good morning everyone i'm judo ken
dieter of the regional center of
excellence on driving crops of the
senegalese institute for agricultural
research israel
and i'm going to present to you siwa
club innovation in west africa
cy aims to modernize our breeding
pipeline to accelerate genetic gain and
crop development that meet demand and
contribute to development
which is aligned with the future and lca
vision
aiming at the development of improved
variety for key product profiles
that underpin economic growth resilience
and nutrient developmental goals
together we trust that
nas like israel could drive innovation
innovative agreed to investment that
breaks the poverty and hunger cycle in
west africa
the rationale behind siwa
revolves around the opportunity to make
very significant yield gain in farmer's
field
to take advantage of our availability
and affordability of
two technology and methodologies
and to utilize well-defined product
profile to drive the development of new
variety that reflect consumer
development and various and use quality
as well as serving the needs of small
order farmers and local variation
israel service has benefit of the west
africa
agricultural poetry program it was a
ten-year program like none other western
africa
nurse to enter specific targeted crops
to lead and to evolve from a national
center of specialization to a regional
center of excellence following equals
criteria the aim were to innovate
disseminate and ease the adoption of
technologies
as here represented by the arrows you
can see that all the technology sharing
between countries
this program also has contributed to
address youth employment women's
inclusion and resilience to climate
change to strengthen humans and
institutional capacity in west africa
and to pass the condition for regional
collaboration
the innovation and crop improvement in
west africa network
shortened by java here regroups breeders
from nas program
since 2015
they access annually poorly genetic
material according to the
to standardize phenotypic methods and
the unique
uh repository breeding management system
bms
and they gathered twice a year to share
their results with stakeholders from
seed producer to processor and dealers
by hosting siwa at isra service in
senegal the scoop of siwa built on the
regional approach hunted by lc to
accelerate crop improvement and
dissemination across west africa towards
the stakeholders farmers beneficiary
the appreciated countries are nigeria
and burkina faso
and the targeted crops are sorghum
preliminary and cowpea they are mandated
crops for israelis from equals the tree
crops are well adapted to the
environment and constitutes staple food
for population
therefore the polish productivity gain
will underpin nutritional and food
security resilience and economic growth
particularly for vulnerable group
the first objective of
is to update existing building product
profile bpps
master student gender expert breeders
stakeholders and social economists will
wait to the balance to help
understand factors and preferences of
addiction as well as market
accessibility
to deploy updated breeding product
profile in pipelines and accelerate new
variety development
threats related to productivity
nutrition and decisions will first be
targeted some other threats showing
higher priorities or needs will also be
inserted in the bpps
further tested ttms will be applied to
those for rapid variety development
the second objective is to implement
modern ttms for rapid discovery and
validation of threats
and diagnostic markers for genetic gain
and product concept development
targeted ttms are g and qtl sequencing
forward selection
duas qtl mapping and we're going to use
also to go higher approach
we will test the haploid haploid
induction and tc regeneration in poly
minute and second
crops and threat in sargon we're going
to target photoperiodism protein
digestibility and green mold
polymer directorians and higher nutrient
contents will be targeted
in cowb maturity seed size and straggler
resistance will be our trait of interest
the objective three is to use genomic
selection and we'll get on prediction of
crop building value
they show huge potential to explore and
increase the genetic gain postulation in
a brilliant per unit timeline
there are economical and viable
alternative to market asset selection
and philanthropic assessment for
quantitative threats key advantage
is that decision insulation can be made
during the off-season leading to crop
improvement in genetic gain on an annual
basis
by designing efficient training
population with both genetic and
phenotypic data genomic estimation
building value of a testing population
that have only genomic data could be
predicted by utilizing general white
high throughput dna markers that are in
lg with qtl of interest
will genome prediction models are being
developed and optimized
in crops
for example at increased partner in siwa
model was used to predict grain yield
for test cross and for hybrid in the
performance of polymered grain yield
early and led towards stress tolerance
and of course various environments
area of inquiries like threat discovery
and genomic selection also successfully
deploy the particle haplotype graph in
circle
the objective four is to routinely use
aerial visual and underground phenotypic
techniques like travelogue mexico
root threat screening methods for drug
tolerance like laser ablation tomography
coupled with deep learning algorithms
that we are developing at cerros
in collaboration with the university of
nottingham and
penn state university
micronutrient contents great quality and
further digestibility of varieties that
we are being developed under siever
will be assessed with
near-infrared spectrometry and x-ray
fuel resonance platform
available at cerras
isroceras is also hosting the integrated
breeding platform up to foster the use
of the bms currently used by solgar
millet and cowboy breeders in different
national program
atonic data capture and management are
critical stepping stone in building and
crop improvement
an integrated analytic pipeline
is allowing readers to digitalize and
track their activities using
electronic data capture tablets
and to conduct effective analysis
sharing interpretation and use of the
data
data management at hns is connected on
an institutional pms
instance stored in the cloud
additional bms insights have also been
implemented to manage rational trials
testing and store data correct from
common materials
evaluating a different location
although the digitalization of breeding
program in the region is moving ahead
well with the support of the ibp some
further support for adoption is
necessary to bring all program to the
same level
of adoption
and to reach the rooting use of the bms
the objective here will be to develop
tests and deploy new functionality and
new apps like the backed ap for data
capture and analysis
siewer cross-cutting activities will
address the question how women and youth
participate or decide
in and benefit from two main notes of
the crop value chain pollution and
processing
this will consist of understanding and
addressing gaps in the knowledge
regarding their participation and
decision making process in seed system
and the benefit of income variety and
processing opportunities
helping breeders to integrate gender and
resilient nutrition in their bpps
and thus empowering early career
research female and youth and breeders
and stakeholder farmers
so see why we therefore complement and
reinforce israel servers currently
designed center of excellence for equals
in particular say we enhance the use of
ttms the implementation of gender
appropriate approach and address the
issue of youth employment and job
creation in west africa
inclusive and past particular approach
will be used to feed information sex and
age constitution
and bridge to ensure that prioritized
product concepts integrate gender
nutrition and resilience in building
pipelines
community engagement and of early career
researchers mentoring by west
established scientists we support a
self-reliance and addressing
cross-cutting team in application
in nurse research and training
activities
here an example of how we do to identify
and to validate constitutive threats
using business population in pearl
millet
we assume that protein is derived from
the integration of favorable alleles
by recurrent crossing scenes exhibits
genetic gains for conservative threats
that are superior to the elderly
sovereign lines
we develop business population by
crossing
female parents threatened for their high
rates of adoption
resistance to download media
medium maturity and good combiner
ability for guilt
and
male parents that are trapped tolerance
striker resistance so early material and
with good combining ability for high
grain quality
picture shows a busy num population
being filled phenotype
under water weight and non-waterway
condition
here is a capture of the protocol and
field book for the screening for striker
resistance in parliament during the
rainy season 2020.
viscose riger virgo using the
classification from one to nine based on
height and number of branches as here
shown
with partners
set of markers are being developed and
their evaluation is yet to be achieved
is how we partner with national healthy
food processing institution ita
west african nurse enron in nigeria and
inner in burkina faso
equisat nisha french institution civic
and ird integrated building platform and
kansas state university
great thanks to the u.s government
partners in lc
to the feed the future program
and to you all for your kind attention